bonsoir namur vous allez bien oui passer
une bonne soirée
tant mieux alors on va continuer alors
je suis extrêmement heureuse d'être ici
ce soir et pour l'occasion
alors ceux qui me connaissent ne s'en
étonneront pas je vous propose de
m'accompagner faire du shopping
oui un non ne vous tracassez pas rester
bien confortablement installé dans votre
fauteuil
je vous emmène surfer sur la toile vous
savez sur le mode un clic
je remplis mon panier je valide et c'est
parti quel luxe
quelle révolution pour tous les fans de
shopping du monde entier alors deviner
ce que nous allons mettre dans notre
panier ce soir une petite idée du du du
sperme mardi du sperme exactement bravo
vous et ils auraient dit si on peut être
du sperme
ok si ça joue va venir vous dit
elle va encore nous montrer des sites
américains là où l'éthique n'a pas le
vent en poupe où la seule loi qui va et
c'est la loi du marché
eh bien oui je suis pas très fier mais
dans un premier temps j'ai été tenté de
faire mon shopping outre atlantique
un choix incomparable des dentistes des
musiciens des athlètes des physiciens
pas de profs du nifff mais des premiers
de classe tout de même et puis très vite
très vite mon choix s'est porté sur gus
le donneur du mois de janvier parce que
j'ai fait mon shopping en janvier fait
les soldes
voilà alors glisse c'est vraiment le mec
parfait
franchement peut difficilement mieux
faire fort athlétique grand évidemment
blond les yeux bleu-vert tester
génétiquement contre plus de 20 maladies
diplômé en biochimie garantissant vince
être juif c'est écrit je n'invente rien
je voulais la place et celle là quand
même
et puis je me suis dit géraldine
géraldine pourquoi ne contribuerait tue
pas à la croissance de l'économie
européenne
et c'est là que je me suis souvenu que
la plus grande banque de sperme au monde
et est implantée non loin de chez nous
au danemark à une entreprise florissante
c'est pas du sperme au rabé croyez moi
c'est du sperme de luxe la crème de la
crème si je puis me permettre
alors on y va on remplit notre petit
panier en forme de poussettes premier
critère de sélection est évidemment la
race la race vu mon profil
on va choisir caucasien temps qu'a fait
faut que ça reste plausible pour la
couleur des cheveux
j'en envie de partir sur du blond plus
enfoncée anon parent ou un surtout par
oh non mais vous savez l'enfer qui
attend un enfant au en cours de
récréation les roues ça pue poil de
carotte ça sent le roussi
tu as pris un coup de soleil à travers
une passoire mais ça sent le vécu
effectivement alors nous mais tout mais
pas ça pour mon enfant s'il vous plaît
la couleur des yeux mais là je m'étais
dit on partirait bien sûr du bleu
variante bleu gris bleu vert peut être
sympa aussi
la taille est mauvaise 1 m 80 89 ça me
paraît dans la moyenne en fin de grand
mais le poids 80 89 kg donc si je calcul
bien j'ai fait l'exercice
on l'obtient l' indice de masse
corporelle tout à fait dans la norme
qu'est ce qu'il nous reste à
sélectionner la motilité la motilité
mais là messieurs c'est le nombre de
spermatozoïdes mobile par millilitre
après décongélation
alors vu que c'est pour une insémination
artisanale à domicile oui alors il ya un
mode d'emploi avec la livraison vous
obtenez le vaudois pour l'insémination à
domicile je les lui c'est très
intéressant à regarder
vu que c'est pour une insémination
artisanale à domicile on va mettre
toutes les chances de notre côté et
opter pour une mobilité maximale
alors qu'est ce qu'il nous reste à haut
profil anonyme versus non anonyme
alors oui non anonyme c'est plus cher
mais bon sang au diable l'avarice tout
de même j'ai fait ma thèse de doctorat
sur le droit de l'enfant de connaître
ses origines
ça serait dommage de renier ses
principes alors the winner is so cute
alors ndi ne porte pas de l'anti il ne
souffre d'aucune anomalie physique
d'aucune allergies il ressemblait à mel
gibson quand il était petit soit vous
souvenez pas fait vous êtes trop jeune
pour avoir connu mel gibson mais si vous
le souhaitez vous cliquez là bas en bas
et vous avez les photos de mel gibson
alors ndi ne roule pas à moto bah oui
tout de même ça réduit le risque
d'accident à l'adolescence il ne fume
pas 0 à une unité d'alcool par semaine
qui dit mieux passer la tournée mines et
raja compte pas mais quand même
qui dit mieux il essaye de manger
sainement ndi il dort sept heures par
nuit samedi son animal préféré
le ch a juste comme moi j'avance emballé
emballez pas vous la pression du
personnel est excellente
l'état compte l'impression du personnel
le profil d'intelligence émotionnelle
est tout à fait dans la moyenne je vous
fais grâce des calculs formidable
j'ajoute dans mon panier alors un stock
pour consommation immédiate
et puis une petite réserve au cas où
jours encore besoin de ses services
formidable on n'arrête pas le progrès
mais là me plus besoin de s'encombrer
d'un homme au quotidien trop âgé pour
utiliser vos propres ovocytes mais pas
de problème pas de problème
les ovocytes deux jeunes femmes superbes
et talentueux sont également disponibles
sur le net
alors pour vous messieurs évidemment
sera le full package mère porteuse
alors américaine si vous avez les moyens
indienne
si les temps sont durs sélectionnez le
sexe mais pas de problème grâce au
diagnostic génétique préimplantatoire
alors moi je vous le dit hein
dans quelques années il y aura plus que
les pauvres qui n'auront d'autre choix
que de se reproduire à l'ancienne et
d'opter pour la procréation mesquine
aléatoire totalement irrationnel tandis
que les autres et bien le programme rend
l'identité biologique de l'enfant à
naître et ça sera merveilleux
voilà la séance de shopping est terminée
et je remercie
non vous vous doutez bien ce n'est pas
terminé on ne veut pas terminer
effectivement blague à part
blague à part tout ce que je viens de
vous montrer là c'est pas de la
science-fiction ah non ça existe déjà
ça existe et c'est en réalisant ma thèse
je voulais dit qu'il porte le droit de
l'enfant de connaître ses origines que
je suis tombé sur ces sites et j'ai eu
du mal à y croire et j'ai toujours du
mal à y croire et quand j'en parle
autour de moi les gens ont du mal à y
croire et c'est pour ça que je vous en
parle aujourd'hui n'est-ce pas alors oui
j'ai été interpellé
j'ai immédiatement songé et comment ne
pas y songer aux risques de dérives de
ces pratiques volonté d'amélioration
l'espèce humaine d'éradication de la
maladie du handicap instrumentalisation
des corps chosification de l'enfant à
naître
à quand l'équipe d'insémination rayon
surgelé entre les pizzas les crèmes
glacées non mais ça fait froid dans le
dos tout de même nom et puis je me suis
dit géraldine
géraldine zen respire ok tu ressens un
malaise tu songes à l'eugénisme louis
mais finalement vie avec ton temps mon
sens un fait preuve d'ouverture d'esprit
où elle mal et c'est ainsi qu'à l'issue
d'une de mes conférences un étudiant est
venu me poser la question qui dérange
madame je comprends pas je comprends pas
où est le mal
en quoi est-ce mal de vouloir améliorer
l'espèce humaine d'éradiquer la maladie
le handicap de ne sélectionner que des
donneurs au pedigree supérieur
fini les nains les trisomiques les
débiles emma l'intelligence moyenne
fini les myopes les asthmatiques et les
roues dans la foulée c'est ça non mais
comprenons nous bien je suis pas là ce
soir prouve a sommé de convictions
morales ou religieuses et vous dire mon
dieu c'est mal non non je souhaite
saisir l'occasion qui m'est donnée
aujourd'hui pour que vous m'accompagner
dans ce questionnement
jusqu'où aller où poser les limites
faut-il même poser des limites
a priori vouloir aider un couple stérile
qui ne peut pas avoir d'enfant mais
c'est une bonne chose
utilisez les tests prénataux le
diagnostic génétique pré implantatoire
pour supprimer l'embryon malades
sélectionnées le plus fort en quoi est
ce mal payé une femme pour porter mon
enfant ou mettre le prix fort pour avoir
les meilleurs spermatozoïdes meilleur
ovocytes possible mais ça dérange ti si
j'en ai les moyens alors j'ai pas de
réponse à vous soumettre ma réflexion
est en cours et je voulais la partager
est-ce qu'on laisse faire et si oui
jusqu'où
car le désir de l'homme de maîtriser le
début et la fin de la vie il est
vachement puissant et pour les
transhumanistes tout progrès
scientifiques ou technologiques et
nécessairement à mieux va devenir plus
beau plus forts plus intelligents ils re
plus longtemps le pied et dans cette
conception le programme doit pas être
questionnés et ben moi j'ai envie de le
questionner j'ai envie qu'on essaye de
réveiller un peu notre esprit critique
comprennent un petit peu de recul qu'on
réfléchisse ensemble au monde que l'on
veut demain devrait quand même pas
oublier que progrès de la science ne
rime pas nécessairement avec progrès de
l'humanité
alors je pense mais ça n'engage que moi
que tout savoir demande à être humanisée
que la course technologique ne devrait
jamais être une fin en soi pour ne pas
oublier que ce qui nous rend humain
c'est aussi cette part de hasard à la
naissance c'est l'acceptation de notre
vulnérabilité l'être humain fondée sur
ces failles c'est aussi ça qui fait sa
singularité
car quand bien même tous les enfants à
l'avenir serait conçu est sélectionné en
laboratoire il resterait à gérer cette
absence de perfection qui nous
caractérise aucun être humain aussi beau
si fort si intelligent soit il ne peut
venir au monde exempt du risque de
développer un jour une maladie grave au
cours de son existence la sécurité
absolue sur le bébé à naître oublier
utopie faut pas oublier que par exemple
je peux sortir d'ici avoir un accident
de voiture de cheval qu'importe de moto
et me retrouvais plus vulnérables alors
je pense que face aux progrès de la
science
l'être humain encore son mot à dire
l'être humain a encore son mot à dire et
en tant que juriste je pense que le
droit a encore son mot à dire et même
pire qui doit le dire je crois dans les
droits humains les droits de l'homme
consacre la solidarité la dignité de
l'homme le respect de l'homme dans sa
différence
alors oui bien sûr en tant que parents
ou futurs parents
on souhaite tous le plus beau bébé
possible en parfaite santé un enfant
qu'il fasse une brillante carrière
docteur en sciences juridiques par
exemple mais c'est oublier que la
naissance d'un enfant
c'est toujours une ouverture vers
l'incertitude vers la nouveauté et la
philosophe hannah arendt nous rappelle
ainsi que la mise au monde d'un enfant
n'est pas une oeuvre un projet que l'on
pourrait mener à bien et contrôler
parfaitement non elle est de l'ordre de
l'action et de la création de nouveautés
avec tous les espoirs et les aléas de la
nouveauté
alors moi ce qui me fait peur mais là
messieurs c'est pas la science non c'est
l'indifférence la différence devant la
sélection humaine qui est ainsi en train
de se mettre en place sans que ça
n'émeuve personne indifférent ce qui
peut-être explique tout simplement par
l'ignorance car qui parmi vous
connaissez l'existence de marchés avant
ce soir
alors je souhaitais tout simplement vous
montrer cette réalité et vous inviter à
vous questionner voir à vous positionner
en tant que citoyen sur le monde que
vous voulez pour vos enfants demain et
je terminerai par ces quelques mots du
philosophe allemand à la jeunesse la
question n'est pas cela marchera-t-il
non ça fonctionne c'est un business
florissant non la question est à quoi
l'homme doit-il s'habituer à quoi at-on
le droit de le forcer à s'habituer
je vous remercie pour votre attention
et hop